[Music]
[Music]
we talk about Julian things amongst
other things mostly Jenna and Julian's a
general doing things this week's episode
is brought to you by Credit Karma
don't pay for your credit score get it
for free with Credit Karma
you can text Jenna Julian right now to
the number 89 800 and get a link sent
back to you where you can download their
free app once you get that app you are
on your way to checking your foot credit
score for free no strings attached at
all to get you your credit score for
free they give you all sorts of options
to help you have a good eye on an
accurate credit score his credit scores
are important we will talk about that
later they are so important they're
important they're so important Thank You
Credit Karma yeah thank you yes so liar
liar what a great flick dead and dead
that dad he's like punching his head and
it's like do you know what's wrong I
don't know
that's such a scare like thing that that
bad I think I'd be really concerned if I
said that to someone and they knew what
I was afraid I wouldn't be concerned I
would have found a new best friend
best friends yeah [ __ ] you Dale and then
he's like he's like there he's probably
going like 80 miles an hour cuz this
planes on the runway and he's just going
like this punching his neck and he looks
over and people are just like looking at
him like yeah the end of that movie
should have been like him going to jail
for a long time
no he just gets carried away in a
stretcher and he's fine everything's
good no laws were broken you didn't get
thrown in a federal prison yeah cuz they
just they understand I mean be honest if
you have some stairs
up at the airport tsa whatever you saw
Jim Carrey doing that you'd be like all
right he's cool he's go didn't he broke
every single rule we ever wrote but I'm
not gonna get it Wow so we wanted to
talk about some really real life stuff
on the podcast so real very real okay
guys well you want well first you know
it came from a tweet
okay this tweet said something along the
lines of you know what I'm gonna find it
right now because they deserve credit I
know I saw it too they tooted it at me
too
yeah it was along the lines of you
should read it
yes read it okay ready Molly be hon on
Twitter podcast debate idea with
vigilantes heroes actually benefit
society so that got me thinking you know
we could talk about a would the
superheroes we know about fictional
superheroes we know about today in 2015
benefit society how would it go down
like if they existed right now with
everything technology wise and otherwise
what would be the ramifications of that
so we're going to talk about spider-man
Batman and Superman what would happen if
they were real right now and out there
being vigilantes and then we are going
to each come up with our own superhero
that we think we bring you rose plural
okay that should exist multiple that
should exist right now that would
greatly benefit everyone in this day and
age yeah so like I said guys this is
these are real-life issues we're getting
the hard-hitting stuff on this podcast
so hard
where's Tamron Hall wait back up tell
them you Tamron Hall is Tamron hall is
an anchor and reporter investigative
journalist I guess on Dateline but she
also has her own show now called murders
with tamarind crying people with
tamarind is its own like I make Julianne
watch own a George Lopez more than own
but I'll settle for own
that's when we're going to bed we're
either watching George Lopez
spongebob drives you or Dateline dr.
Phil comes on tour but usually we're in
bed button before that but sometimes if
it's late night we're like oh [ __ ] it's
dr. filming right when dr. Phil comes on
it goes didn't and I go click asleep
yeah and always sounds good and then dr.
Phil comes on yes dr. Phil but that is
like hard [ __ ] you're always late
it's just not an hour you need to be
awake yeah plus sometimes that show just
really makes me like one bang my head on
something it's irresponsible sorry those
what's yours oh he's an office cool [ __ ]
I fell for it again
Kelly's talking about bingley right in
it so damn it to know the show it's just
it's irresponsible time I'd leave it
maybe's other stuff did you see on [ __ ]
you Anna
mamrie's show oh my god how did she get
Angelo she got Angela from office oh my
god what I wouldn't [ __ ] give to I
know I can meet her I commented this is
so dope did you really I did because it
was half for you Julian really you would
really appreciate it
Angela from the office collaborated with
me Marie that is so cool that's like I
feel like I met her because I know
mamrie mamrie touched memory and memory
is touched Angela
so I've literally made out with Angela
yes right you call that she had a baby
so anyway enough about that fictitious
mother I think it's actually shut up
about the son guys have made an office
reference really proud of myself
shut up about the son shut up about the
sir
slams on tape anyways let's let's get
into these vigilante heroes is this
supposed to be like professional because
we suck we suck yeah we always suck
that's part of its charm is that it
sucks [ __ ] like a podcast like it's not
the room he can hear you is right vodka
hi sorry podcast
okay let's service Superman alright okay
and I think we should leave out as much
of the backstory as we can because
that's just gonna distract it okay all
right we get it
okay so first of all Superman let's go
for the debate of Superman easy good or
bad let's start with that do you think
he would benefit or hurt society all in
one question like just over all right
okay overall I feel like for the most
part the superheroes that we've grown to
love cause a very big and realistic
problem and that they just have these
like massive personally driven dramas
that they play out that like cost
millions of dollars worth of damage yeah
like there could be a whole series of
movies and television shows just based
on the lives of the people that have to
clean up after superheroes that's really
funny
thank you I'm proud of myself for that
one that's really funny like just
imagine how much you hate your life like
you you really want to go to your kids
play but you can't because [ __ ]
Superman just tossed a plane into the
ocean and like you know wrecked a bridge
trying to save his girlfriend and he may
not have even saved her because it's
still the middle of the movie you missed
your daughter's play because Superman's
yes your name is Bill and your wife
Sally is [ __ ] had it with you and
Sally she's ready to leave the team
she's ready to leave you oh my god oh my
god you're kidding some flowers figure
it out man your wife your wife is having
another baby because she's trying to fix
the marriage with it oh okay this got
way too [ __ ] real sorry like
you're you trying you're going under
anything already okay well done well
done
I like that segue okay Karma yeah what
is that noise what sounds a good plan
I'm just you know in in the school of
thought like I used to really really
really enjoy all of the the comic book
hero movies and you know I've read a lot
of the comics yeah and look I'm a fan
I've loved it we just watched an episode
of x-men recently the cartoon show and
oh my god it was [ __ ] I know you're
loving that I know everything except for
that one guy morph or whatever the [ __ ]
his name it I didn't remember him at all
because jason said he dies looks like oh
that explains it he dies like mad early
yeah that's what we want anyways I'm a
fan I really like it as I you know grew
up in that older I feel like a lot of
you know what's being made is very
repetitive and it always leaves me with
that like well what the [ __ ] about all
the regular people like what the [ __ ]
about the people that worked in that
office building that the Green Goblin
just slammed his little [ __ ] scooter
spike air thing into like [ __ ] off I'd
be so pissed yeah write a cover board
before all the miners did what about all
the realists yeah well I would say up
there with some of the most destructive
superheroes is Iron Man and the Hulk
they just wreck the [ __ ] out of anything
how is that helping people well
it's available but we're talking about
Superman he can be pretty reckless too
but okay get me started on [ __ ]
Supergirl
Supergirl can go ahead and not on my
television they need a stuff I'm sorry
I'm just gonna drag right now but they
need establish noting that down my
throat yeah I do you remember that Star
net live skit of like Marvel knows women
or whatever that's like cheesy like I'm
in love I'm just kidding he left me ah
it's the Black Widow
it's really good you can look it up on
YouTube I think but the preview for
Supergirl is almost exactly like that
yeah it's in the worst way that's the
worst thing and it's they're trying to
mark it as something new and
groundbreaking when it's been done a
billion times it's not original is not
well done and in the preview for the
television show they show her trying to
save her [ __ ] sister and like you
know breaking a bridge and like throwing
a plane into the ocean and [ __ ] like the
most destructive stuff for your [ __ ]
personal problems yeah
you don't even probably her personal
[ __ ] too like the [ __ ] right just
imagine Supergirl I mean I'm gonna go
ahead and just bury my own [ __ ]
gender over here but like when I'm
PMSing like everybody's going down you
know what I mean yeah yeah totally I
like you'd accidentally kill someone you
thought was a villain then you'd be like
oh [ __ ] man I'm sorry too it's like you
texted me something and I'm just not in
a good mood yeah or worse you're like
out front arguing with your boyfriend
and you like get mad so you like punch
the ground and he goes flying to the
moon you're like [ __ ] I didn't mean that
yeah I did okay well since we're staying
on topic so well I'm just I'm going to
say that's Superman I'd say he could do
some good I'd say I don't think it would
be unanimous obviously it's gonna be a
hundred percent dependent on who he is
kind of working with if you will like I
don't want to get into government too
much and stuff like that like yeah but
you know if if he chose to like you know
when you're watching the Superman movies
and he's kind of like it's throughout
the parts where he's kind of just saving
random people you know and he's kind of
everywhere at once that aspect 100%
would be great but then again you're
like if he cooperates with the wrong
people it could be disastrous but that
goes for any time period I think it's
specific to this time period I mean I
don't know like it's interesting because
like what if someone's flying a drone
right and Superman like flies and just
knocks it out and then they're like dude
I like saved up for a year to buy the
Badger and super I didn't even feel it
because he's going 3,000 miles an hour
he's in like Japan in two seconds and
his drones broken and the guy who was on
the line for that
who's on the line three days for that
drum I mean you know you're the
manufacturers not gonna go super mad bro
key yeah let's get your replacement
they're gonna be like buy another one
and then say you do buy let me save up
another year and then [ __ ] Superman
flies through again and maybe he doesn't
ruin your drum this time but maybe he
ruins the best shot you ever got
maybe he ruins the roof of your house so
or your cornfields no I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say because the drones exist
Superman doesn't even think we can get
the question though because then the
movies and stuff he's always hanging
around and you know whatever but it's
America right if we had a Superman like
that would he just be like our American
vision does he go around the world
singing
as you said Japan but is that like is he
gonna save Japanese people because if I
weren't the pan I'd be like you better
[ __ ] share him
well that's the thing okay so it's
Superman capable of saving like a
thousand people in a second like it
seems like he is in the movie or is he
not because if he's not then it's just
like okay you're saving like I'm an
American a day like great and I don't
think he would say about non-american I
say he's an American Hero like he saves
America he hangs out in the States true
and judging by how much damage he does
like we can't really afford to have you
I feel like like a like a group of
supermen would would benefit us more
than only if they have better outfits
that red blue yellow thing is tacky
she needs to snatchin how much damage he
would cause if he like whipped and you
just like don't come around and like
broke all the bridges within a mile so
what's the consensus on Superman I would
say if I'm preferring he exists or not I
don't say no that's the he would
probably cause more [ __ ] than do good I
agree
get out Superman fly away Superman year
you're done you weave I spent so much
money on that drone and you just like
disintegrated it yeah I'd be pissed that
you're gone who's gonna pay for whatever
and whatever
all right who's the next Superman Batman
stay okay same thing for me this
[ __ ] drives his little Batmobile
through bridges and knocks them all down
okay Batman I'm gonna feel a little
differently because I feel like Batman
really goes into the thick of it in
terms of like shitty people and fights
them yeah and I keep my son really
fucked-up villains agreed well so you're
saying he's good yeah I would say I mean
it was like I don't know Superman's like
always saving the world and [ __ ] you
know fighting these giant super powers
but Batman's like killing off thugs and
[ __ ] you know what I mean like killing
off people who are actually killing
people in front of you
mm-hmm yeah but also he's a Batman is
like a Bruce Wayne whatever yeah I know
I'm like I'm looking at the dough sekiz
man it's not really could feel everyone
comments about his hand right here
ukulele behind usually yeah this guy
he's like a [ __ ] billionaire and what
does he do he doesn't you know help set
up charities and like do good [ __ ] no he
just builds himself a Batcave to like
you know relive his [ __ ] Batman [ __ ]
it I'm sorry but isn't there a level of
you know being a billionaire you have
sort of an obligation to the rest of the
world to really do some good like Bill
Gates or like Oprah okay hold on the
whole game [ __ ] Foundation's to how
you're talking about Batman yeah
not pursue and well that's the same
person I'm sorry and the Clark Kent is
not Superman and Batman is not Bruce
Wayne they are different people oh my
really
they embody different lives yes they yes
like we were talking okay you're making
valid points can't have Batman without
Bruce Wayne because I would say it has
zero dollars
in this fictitious world we're living in
imagine that Bruce Wayne lives in Gotham
and that doesn't exist in our world but
super Batman does exist in our world so
when he turns back in the Bruce Wayne he
morphs back into the other world that
doesn't exist in real life all right
I'll go with that
it's just I'm still gonna say no I do
not if I ever had a kid I want I don't
not want Batman on the road I don't want
that man on the road myself honey put on
your blinker the Batmobile on it yeah
any major highway in the United States
and he's just killing everyone on it
because he wants to go you know make
sure that somebody doesn't explode in a
jail yeah [ __ ] off he's an irresponsible
driver the DMV would suspend his license
so fast yeah of course they'd be like
all right sir take your mask off so he
can take your picture I can't oh my god
there well so you think he should exist
I think you should because he would go
around fighting like this communists of
crooks and you know actually saving like
I can I can imagine like a situation
where someone is really in trouble on
the street somewhere and Batman comes up
and just [ __ ] pummels a couple of
people who were about to do really bad
[ __ ] you know yeah it's not just flying
through the goddamn air right to do
whatever Superman's gonna do yeah I see
what you're saying in that like Batman
really is a vigilante hero yeah and
Superman is like selfish and in love
yeah like Superman's driven by all this
weird [ __ ] Batman is just like a [ __ ]
tortured soul yeah like hangs out in a
cave and then when he's in his suit he
goes and [ __ ] up people hmm know people
who deserve it
I'm I'm for Batman but I am biased he is
my favourite superhero of all time so
Batman yes zoom in oh I bet you did I
mean you're right now I'm like punch you
for that
I'm scared anyways so you're knowing no
yeah you're too no I think that
logistically it would cause too many
problems because then what laws apply to
Batman like when you have a vigilante
well you know what justifies going and
beating somebody up if he's doing it
before they committed crime then you're
in a [ __ ] world of legal hurt I mean
it's it's tough because like you would
you would a hundred percent need to
treat them differently because they are
different like there's no sense in being
like oh he's a person dude he's not
[ __ ] person he's a Superman he's
superhero like he has different powers
therefore he should have different rules
so Batman doesn't have any powers he
just has a [ __ ] ton of money you can
kind of fly with that cape I mean let's
be [ __ ] honest here like oh no you
can't you can't [ __ ] me okay they can't
you like okay so yeah it's mostly just
like things and like cool you know
[ __ ] Batman ninja stars flying out of
his arrest and [ __ ] but it's like it's
mostly like he can [ __ ] he can handle
he jumps off giant you know he it's not
just its technology it's not it's not
Iron Man is a technology okay cuz you
take him out of the suit he does zero
Batman it's kind of an ass kicker he can
fry a little bit with a cape like
everyone else with a cape has powers he
doesn't have powers yet he can somehow
still sort of fly sort of emphasis on
the fly emphasis something somehow I
just I really want to know like what
Batman eats and does for his workout
routine because why is he so much more
jacked than every other human ever like
if he stood next to the rock the way
they make him look man like he could
beat up the rock yeah
which realistically I find hard to
believe because nobody eats more and
works harder than the rock nobody works
harder than nobody comes even [ __ ]
close to be working as hard as a rock
don't ever he probably does he probably
works it yeah that he would stand next
to the rock and he'd be like well yeah
the rock is the bigger first to meet you
klokov is an incredibly hard worker he
is an absolute specimen and he never
gives up his work ethic like he's
accomplished so much yet he continues to
just like
Demitri clothes no as an Olympic
weightlifter he is in Olympic he's
Weiser officially retired at Olympic
weightlifting he is big in the crossfit
scene and he is an Olympic champion I'm
not mistaken he won I forget what medal
but uh his his dad was an Olympic
champion he's one of the greatest
waiters of our time and he goes around
the entire world and puts on these
insane clinics where he breaks his own
records of weightlifting and it's like
it's ridiculous you know look him up on
Instagram Aviv cloaca D on Instagram
he'll post a video of him doing
something and you're just like oh my
[ __ ] god it's like you just robbed
audio and woke up and in like had your
coffee and your breakfast and dmitry
klokov head has already done you know so
many [ __ ] snatches around a track so
so much do you weight lifters who know
I'm talking about this is a pause snatch
where you pause as you're lifting it 190
kilos
[Applause]
he's still holding it yeah he's a freak
and Mike is a freak like he somehow I
mean I don't know he's here's my thing
if we made Batman so your son can't be
Bruce Wayne because they exist
separately King dmitry klokov be Batman
can you think can he be his alter ego or
can he be Batman in the suit yeah if we
had to pick a Batman if we had to pick a
person to go in a suit to be back in or
I would pick the rock or dmitriy klokov
I don't pick the rock for Superman then
I would pick yes to Superman QB red
super me yeah he looks great in this
Superman shirt right true somehow in
Superman you have a lot about John Cena
who King John Cena be [ __ ] mom
anyways I think that Batman should not
exist I think he should only because I
think that people dying in car accidents
is too real as it is and he's just not a
responsible driver fair enough fair
enough fair enough
also he could totally just like uh start
like a really successful Etsy store with
all of the cool stuff that he like
carries around like he would make a
killing right but he already has a
killing yeah well here's my other true
here's my other thing so say you were
you know this quote-unquote thug that
Batman is always fighting what if you
know you decided that you wanted to turn
your life around and that you stopped
selling drugs and like robbing people
and then Batman saw you you know doing
something that looks like a crime beat
the [ __ ] out of you like he doesn't care
that you're a different person no he
just
it's all up to his well if you're a
different person why you why are you
appearing like you're a thug but there's
no check you soon saying though there's
no checks and balances to his power do
you think he just attacks blindly
because he thinks for bad yeah well I
think I would think that man would have
a little bit better judgment and that
one man he is only one man I mean like
all right this is getting a little real
here but what if he
he killed the thug who was black and
then everyone was like that man's racist
well then maybe he got a [ __ ] problem
maybe cuz me maybe he is or be maybe
everyone's gonna get like the wrong idea
about it hmm
and then suddenly Batman is bad guy
because he beautiful black guy mm-hmm
and he's a bad driver yeah I mean some
may say he's such a good driver that
he's a bad driver that's why you say
he's such a bad driver that he's a good
driver well yeah
either way yeah okay no yes I'm one for
Batman you or not what about spider-man
spider-man last one right for the
traditional superheroes I don't know I
didn't I didn't see the second angel
Garfield installment I only saw the
first you still have to see the second
one but I gotta say the kids got a
little bit of a tude man and wife you
know look not him as a person but when
he's in the mood I mean he's like he's
kind of like an entitled teenage kid I
thought he was sweet I liked him in it
oh I didn't mind him but I definitely
feel like I don't want that kid having
powers well yeah I mean he might do a
lot of good but he's a he I guess you
know but here's the thing spider-man in
the comics is very much that kid he's
very much that kid with all these quips
he always says he's very you know come
back ish and he's he's like if the child
had powers basically cuz he is he's a
teenager right he's like in his late
teens well I mean there's storylines
that go all the way yeah I don't know
you saying that wrong but yeah I don't
know I'm kind of on the fence about
spider-man I mean right now I feel like
like okay like we already have Batman
okay he's driving around like a maniac
beat enough bad people like I do we need
spider-man I mean going back to the
drones thing like what if he just I
don't know I can't he is okay no
spider-man does not need to exist
because his job is to take pictures from
his stupid little webs but if you have
drones now you don't need that [ __ ] done
drones coming back for the wedding
spider-man drones make spider-man
irrelevant okay but if we go with the
Family Guy version of spider-man where
it's like everybody gets one like that
that spider-man 2 you see Steve Greene's
video no he took like 40 not 40 like 20
people all dressed up in spider-man and
went to Hollywood in the Highland and
caused hell what happened he lit it
sorry I don't want to cut you he
literally got dressed up in spider-man
and had 20 something other people dress
up in spider-man and they went to
Hollywood and Highland where they have
like there's the transformer guy there's
a spider-man there's bad it's a tourist
attraction towards there's always like a
Johnny Depp and then people go there
take pictures he's hairy
yeah and basically the message he's
trying to convey is that like why you
guys why are you charging these guys for
pictures will be in everyone's picture
and then they photo bomb every single
picture on Hollywood and Highland
pissing off the transformer guy pissing
off the other Batman they all think
they're like oh my I see them and then
the cops don't care it's really funny
that is amazing yeah yeah like it looks
so it's like runnin with backpacks on
and [ __ ] coming down Steve his next
level he's next level anyways about
spider-man like I think I would like to
have a Spider Man if he saved everyone
once like the Family Guy version and he
gets one yeah um but again with the mess
yeah and your personal problems yeah
like yeah you're a teenager in your
moody and it's always about [ __ ] Gwen
Stacy in the right head chick and again
Mary Jane pick God [ __ ] for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ] that one of them dies something
they both die everyone's dead what
everyone's dead I used to play the
spider-man video game when I was a kid
and if you failed this one level it
literally would just say MJ died because
it was just like oh [ __ ] MJ died like
you lost a level but Angie died brings a
whole new level of response
exactly right it's too intense and also
again back to the Superman thing this
[ __ ] just leaves his webs
everywhere that's disgusting I don't
want to live in that garbage like [ __ ]
off unless you hire a cleaning crew to
clean up after your webby discussing
this don't do it around me web webby
it's a weird word webby webby webby mess
in that movie I love how Peter Parker
Andrew Garfield yeah just happened to
make himself the most sophisticated like
Under Armour [ __ ] spider-man suit
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] song and
they made it seem like this [ __ ]
sat down at a sewing machine and sewed
that [ __ ] I'm sorry but someone that's
like you couldn't get Michael Kors to
sew that [ __ ] it was ridiculous true
yeah yeah even the guys on face off
couldn't sew that couldn't even vacuum
but I think that spider-man is too
wrapped up in his own business to
actually be a true vigilante you know
justice hero yeah he's got to run after
a girl 90% of the time so aggressive is
like do we need this guy no he just I
feel like I'm living in spider world yes
it's just webs everywhere
alright so I think we're both no.1
spider-man yeah the only one I would be
okay with maybe if you cleaned up his
driving his [ __ ] Batman yeah what if
he just rode around the motorcycle less
damage unless accidents cuz if he gets
the next and he's getting hurt so get
get rid of the Batmobile he's done like
a [ __ ] titanium suit like he hits the
ground you would usually die from a
[ __ ] motorcycle crash like that but
because he's wearing that badass suit he
bounces off the ground and hits an SUV
with an entire [ __ ] family everyone
else is bad god he's also coated in like
25 pounds of solid good muscle what I'm
saying what does he eat well yeah he
eats the good stuff I would trust the
rock if he were Batman and it was his
job to be better no cloak offs Batman
The Rock is Superman okay I'm okay with
both okay cool because I also trust
their judgment yeah Dimitri would not
beat a single person up that like wasn't
absolutely like all the way or
deep in a [ __ ] crime yeah yeah yeah
yeah first then he'd probably [ __ ]
benchpress them afterwards for sure and
I know Andrew Garfield or spider-man is
young but age isn't the most important
number in your life mmm nor is it your
IQ right it's your credit score your
credit score is one of the most
important numbers in your entire life
and did you know something I just read
that 25 percent of people in the United
States have errors in their credit score
because of going to faulty sites or
going about it wrong that all is not a
problem when you go to Credit Karma
you get free credit scores you get the
option with the Credit Karma app which
you can get for free I'll tell you how
and it's also at the bottom of the
screen but you have the option will you
get your credit score right away no
credit card nothing there's no strings
attached there's no cash you get your
credit score right away it is accurate
it's there for you but you also get the
option to have monitoring alerts tips on
how to improve and all this stuff but
it's it's it's so much more than just
getting your credit score you log in and
they have all these tools for you to
help you because credit scores are
hugely important they're important in
your finances important in every auto
loan every home loan everything you do
big financial wise in your life your
credit score comes into effect so it's
important to have a grasp on what that
is and what it really is not what you
may think it is my stepdad is a
financial genius he monitors the stock
market he does all sorts of stuff
because he's a financial genius and the
only time I had ever asked anyone what
to do to get my credit score because it
is confusing there's a lot of stuff out
there he said go to Credit Karma and
this was years before now I was like
what do I do
Credit Karma and I was going on
expecting to have to type in a bunch of
credit card info have to sign up my
email nope just had to my info got my
credit score and it was accurate caught
it right away there's an app on your
phone what you can do right now is you
text Jenna Julianne 289 800 yes that is
correct and you will get a link that you
click on it it'll download Credit Karma
for free on your phone right now at the
Google Play Store or the App Store and
you you were talking about how you were
with me when I desperately needed is
with you I used to have an old business
manager who was it was his job to help
me you know we paid Rome and like you
know my business and part of his job was
to make sure that my credit was good and
I trusted that he was doing his job and
I went to go move into the our old place
for me live and when you know usually
when you rent an apartment they ask you
for a copy of like your bank statements
and your score sure so that they can
make sure that you're gonna pay your
rent and stuff yeah and he was like your
credits really low and I'm like how is
that possible what do you mean I have
someone that like monitors it for me
this no he did not he completely ignored
it and it got trashed very quickly and
luckily we got back up but I really
honestly wish that I had had something
like that like Credit Karma at the time
because I had no idea that my credit you
know had gone and apps and that's the
biggest part not knowing like not having
an idea of what your credit score
actually is and with Credit Karma you
get that yeah free and if I had had
actual monitor like that I would have
never been in that situation I had to
pay more money upfront to rent this
apartment no then had I had a better
credit you got real life ramifications
of not knowing your credit score go to
Credit Karma right now or text that
number 89 800 million friendly reminder
that you can't always trust a person to
do that kind of thing sometimes you guys
can do it yourself
just trust Credit Karma to do it for you
thanks for the comments Credit Karma
check it out guys okay so I would say at
this point we can now gather the best
ideas and superpowers into one non
existent super here that we think should
exist right okay do you want to go first
or should I go first yeah I have like a
bunch of superheroes wanting you do
go the first one that I want to exist is
the hunger superhero where whenever
you're hungry he just comes and gives
you a snack think of all the global
problems that could be in so high a
hunger superhero so is he is he
basically like as fast as - from The
Incredibles is that how he's able to do
it or just imagine like a Santa for food
okay okay so basically how does it work
how does it work you say I'm hungry and
he shows up or what does it pay well
just timeout for one second because we
don't have to logically explain Superman
or spider-man and how they know where
everything's going on so I'm not going
to explain hunger man okay
don't hold me to that I'm not gonna
logically explain to you how he gets to
every hungry person in the world he just
does their enough fair enough traffic
man basically what this guy does is he
has instead of webs shooting out of his
hands he has roads shooting out of his
body so he can build roads by flying
somewhere and the road is already built
so basically if there's ever an area
that needs expanded roads construction
done basically anything to alleviate
traffic which literally is everywhere in
our world today because so many people
are everywhere he would just fly over
and he would build a road right on top
of it like a second level or somewhere
off the side he could build roads in
seconds Kenny laughs Achmed Kenny also
disassembled the roads oh yeah yeah yeah
big time he can fly through it and then
it would be like a big cloud and he
[ __ ] leaves and you're like key
though he is traffic man because that is
what he does not allow in this world
because he creates a world with no
traffic mmm and it's beautiful thank you
thank you from trademark I also I think
that there should be a like a social
media sort of vigilante yes yes yeah I
think of all of the cases that you've
heard of specifically within the last
ten years of people reporting her
Smit or something on social media to the
police and they they do nothing about it
yes the law hasn't really caught up to
all of it and unless they like pose a
physical threat to you they can't do
anything I wish that there was a social
media vigilante that would just come
into someone's house that was doing that
be like hey Sara
that one was too far you're going down
okay what about that wasn't beautiful by
the way I love what about if you say he
did this there's someone he flies into
their house and he's like hey Sara cut
that [ __ ] out
yeah and then he leaves but then Sara
doesn't stop he goes back to Sara and
he's like okay since you didn't listen I
am attaching a little [ __ ] orb to
your back which means you will never
have access to the Internet no matter
where you are in your entire life it's
basically a scrambler forever no not
forever or four it's like a sentence
like yes anything you touch gets
scrambled offline yes oh my god I feel
like you know some people really don't
care they they're like the stalkers like
these people that are really terrible on
the internet that you hear about
absolutely they they don't care about
going to jail they a lot of them you
know might not be in a good headspace
or as some of them have mental illness
some of them are so so drinking their
own kool-aid they think they'll never
get caught alright ever there's some
people that you know know how to use the
internet and a very sophisticated way I
think that if you took someone that
lives and breathes the internet and is
so like good at it like think of someone
that's on you know I don't know that is
very good at the Internet the worst that
you can do that person is not like give
them house arrest or probation for
harassing someone is to scramble their
internet yeah I would be furious hasn't
that like but not your internet it's any
Internet you touch the scramblers
attached to you I was like can I use
your phone your phone would no longer
have internet oh it's over it okay it's
[ __ ] terrifying right a minute
imagine that no no stupid friends
harassing someone and then she comes
over tries you use your phone and then
it's broken
but I would trust the the social media
vigilante to only only time he's the
best best filter on when people that are
you know potentially dangerous yes he
does not abuse that power yeah cuz he
himself is on Twitter and he can't
[ __ ] lose the energy he knows that
[ __ ] and no one can scramble his
Internet so but just think about all the
people that could have been helped are
crying out to anyone and everyone to
help them the law can't you know
actually do anything about it
would he go up to people like illegally
periscoping like pay-per-view stuff and
be like this is your last chance or I'll
somebody scramble you no way because the
law doesn't protect ya they're not
causing any harm
they're only harming people that's true
no that's true it's not he's not helping
out businesses he's helping out human
beings I don't think it would be social
media vigilantes job to like you know
enforce rules that may or may not be
enslaved right I think it would be the
Vigilant social media vigilantes job to
prevent like bodily physical harm or
amongst people that are being like
harass even yeah or even emotional
harassment stuff like that where people
are bullying and stuff yeah that [ __ ]
up [ __ ] no that would that would
literally be one of the most useful
superheroes we could ever have right now
right well done well done I think that
made good one I like that one I would
just I think it would be so awesome if
you hear about some of those disgusting
people then like drive kids to suicide
and think some dude just came and
knocked on their door and scared the
absolute [ __ ] out of them and threatened
to scramble their internet for five
years is the type of stuff you wish
existed so you could have justice right
that's the justice porn I love well I
see that subreddit justice porn know
basically videos of Justice because kind
of other that's incredible but think
about like you know when you you get
isolated from the internet and you're
soaked used to being on the internet
it's not like you know someone that
lives in the middle of nowhere and then
you take Internet
kind of like I'm never on the Internet
anyways if you take someone that's so
immersed in the world and you cut them
off from it it's jarring to your
existence yes because you demean whether
or not you want to admit it you depend
on that [ __ ] so much for a lot of things
not just one thing right no information
for connections big socialization
everything yep it would be a good
punishment yeah what what especially if
it's like a thirteen year old or 14 year
old oh yeah that they can be the worst
yeah but you can't like throw that kid
jail ya know do you take away his
Internet and it's like Oh a parent can
take like a terrible but a parent we can
take your way of home but that does
nothing the kid's gonna find his baby on
the internet but with this little orb
implanted in the middle of his scramble
everything everything he touches breaks
the internet and doesn't let him onto it
Oh too bad man - that would be amazing
imagine that if that invention was
invented of real life it would be abused
instantly but um no that's a great
superhero I like that one okay thanks
all right you have another one I do
um well on the topic of traffic because
I feel strong this superhero I don't
have a name for him but he would
basically fly around to parking lots
various parking lots around the globe
and when a person is parked in a way
that it's taking up two spots he would
just slip they just move their car all
right now there's this spot you can
party basically evening out that would
be so helpful because I mean every law
you go to there's always that one space
that you can't quite fit into because
someone decided to park diagonally like
a [ __ ] and know and you know fight
people fight people leave notes
passive-aggressive no this would all be
gone if he just came and just straighten
it out like just a little bit like all
right I don't mean you think that to be
that strong he's not a fly and then
nowhere the car magnets yeah Google Maps
could work with him so he knows and yeah
just a little shove because mostly it's
just like a diagonal parking job and if
you if you see like a truck parked in a
[ __ ] handicap spot they can just flip
it upside down nice and gently - they're
not damaging the cars just Kendra
except yeah no that's that's that's
about that's all I even do it's pretty
sweet I think so I like it thank you
my next one was not as thoughtful as
that mine was just dog man well he looks
like a dog cyber unlikes
so is he a dog or does he look as a man
that no he's a man dog oh my god man dog
and he watches your dogs when you're out
of town so that someone caring and
understanding and loving and knows what
song people are out of town at once he
just goes back and forth really fast
well he okay so he's any more of his
blob he can like it I like it yeah dog
man dog man okay I got one
what is his name is mo fee man he
charges your father instantly flies
around the charges you're dead phone
that reminds me of like he's a giant jet
pack full with energy that's incredible
didn't we were joking about something
like that recently where we would be a
funny video he's so funny but you'd have
to go somewhere really pop you like
you'd have to go to Venice well you'd
have to go somewhere where people are
sitting so like a train or a bus stop or
you like hey is your phone dead let me
help you charge it no you you have them
all on those big long like your words so
that you're standing in the middle and
everyone spider so you're making a giant
fire hazard man does it through there he
just doesn't yeah and so he doesn't
cause a fire it reminds me of an episode
of Jackass where one of them dressed up
as a fairy and was just running around
putting quarters in people's parking
meters and so they got in trouble
because again it's apparently a [ __ ]
legal of course it is how dare you
someone not get a ticket yeah yeah but I
thought that was so fun that's what
Muffy man love you man
I like these I like our group of
superheroes right I feel like it's solid
don't I would want to live in a world
with those superheroes I'm so excited if
there's a dog man yeah dude if I'm
driving right and I'm like [ __ ] it's 4
o'clock I'm gonna take an hour to get
home and three miles away dog then
traffic guy shows up and then he just
like builds a road and it goes right
over the road that's trafficking and
then everyone's happy or if traffic man
was busy and you were worried about your
dogs you could just call dog man and
have them go play with your dog cool so
all of these superheroes have apps that
you can call them on or like let us work
on the Apple watch too so check that out
oh god I wish the The Sandman was a real
thing though when you're trying to sleep
and you can't sleep and he just comes in
that'd be nice like imagine you're on a
[ __ ] airplane yeah I totally wanna
cry and coming into my bedroom and
dropping sin on my face while I'm trying
to sleep that sounds wonderful yeah I
know I I hear saying I would love to be
aided in sleep sometimes because
sometimes I couldn't can't sleep at all
like I went to sleep last night and I
probably woke up 50 times throughout the
night for no good reason
well you were hot maybe that maybe that
thirsty typical Julian classic Julian
Julian's thirsty AF I have all the time
I know which is tooth fairy was real
Oh Jannah you blew it [ __ ] but do you
know what super here we don't need what
is the credit superhero because you have
Credit Karma yeah yeah you are your own
super legendary segue is this fun
guys seriously Credit Karma you are a
credit score's so might as well check
the right one go to Credit Karma or you
can text Jenna Julian that's Jenna I'm
Julian text Jenna Julian 289 eight
hundred to get the link to download the
free app in the Google Play Store or the
App Store if you're an Apple iPhone user
like myself and you get the free app you
get your free credit score and you get
all these options to help you monitor
alert you and help you get an accurate
reading on your credit score and make it
a good one good credit score yeah it
really does make life so much easier
yeah
yeah well you know I mean Mophie man
probably has Credit Karma because in
order to buy that giant jetpack of
energy he had he had to probably drop
some cash no banks gonna give him that
loan without a good credit score Oh
Julian Chris Mel burger face good face
good fades good podcast this is a really
[ __ ] fun podcast yeah it was fun
maybe we'll do it some other time
every superhero you guys you uh you
sometimes see us really great ideas so
thank you for that yeah thank you is
Molly right Molly you rock thanks thank
you for that awesome awesome idea like
how did you even think of that girl if
you want to check her out on Twitter she
had a lively playful disposition which
delighted in anything ridiculous that's
her bio so she sounds like an
interesting girl she does thanks Molly
thanks Molly thanks for listening pretty
wonderful yeah thank you guys for
watching thank you for listening in to
the podcast and make sure to check out
credit , and we'll be back for their
nightmare of a podcast
leave us your comments in the comment
section about what you think about a man
in our made-up superheroes and if you
have any made us really know there's
gonna be a couple of brilliant ones in
the comments just a couple of you guys
aren't that smart
Oh we'll be back with another podcast
and Gillian stuff amongst other stuff I
kind of like that I might start seeing
that where we talked about Jenna and
Julie and stuff among so that sound like
they're mostly Jenna and then we
high-five
all right later guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]